row upon row of sophisticated assault
rifles boxes of pistols ammunition
vision equipment videos posted by the
taliban online in recent days boast of
what they say are their seizures of the
assault rifles in the afghan city of
herat and at kunduz airport armored
humvees by the dozen some mine resistant
ambush protected vehicles called m wraps
costing half a million dollars a piece
even a small drone
these are the potentially lethal spoils
the taliban are believed to have
captured in recent days from defeated
afghan forces weapons made in america
supplied by the u.s to their fallen
afghan allies
so now we're arming the taliban and
marooning our own citizens in
afghanistan who could possibly have seen
that coming glenn greenwald is one of
the few journalists who did see it
coming
he writes for sub stack where all of us
read him you should too he joins us
tonight glenn thanks so much for coming
on so it's a little weird for the news
organizations that repeated uncritically
and not just on the left i i hate to say
it but almost all of them just repeated
these this kind of happy talk about how
afghanistan was progressing for 20 years
and then they whip around and are
shocked that actually it's a mess and
always have been there's some dishonesty
there isn't there
the whole thing was a fraud and you know
you can go
back to things like in 2019 the
washington post publishing what it
called the afghanistan papers there's
now a book out by the reporter who broke
that really important story they did a
good job on it where they obtained
secret documents going up through 2016
under the obama years where internally
they were saying the exact opposite of
what they were saying publicly about the
war in afghanistan just like they did in
vietnam as revealed by the pentagon
papers they were saying to the public as
you just showed we're making great
progress we have faith in the afghan
national security forces internally they
knew the afghan national security forces
were a joke they were filled with
illiterate people who couldn't do
anything with drug addicts so people who
had no interest in fighting they would
disappear as soon as they got their
paycheck the whole war for years and
years and years was a lie and so
while i do agree of course that there
are ineptitudes and how we withdrew the
fact that we withdrew because two
presidents first president trump and
then president biden
ensured that it happened is something to
celebrate in large part because it's the
first time in as long as i can remember
as these people what i do know is the
deep state that manipulate us all the
time that lie to us all the time for
their own benefit have finally lost and
the media is turning against biden not
because they suddenly became fair but
because they've been in bed with the
deep state that's who fed them
russiagate that's who fed them all the
leaks during the trump years and they're
angry on behalf of the faction that they
genuinely serve
well i i hate to say i agree with you i
mean i i think biden is an awful
president the worst i can remember and
totally out of it senile on the other
hand he's the president united states
you're not supposed to leak
an audio tape of his recorded
conversation with another head of state
i mean that's that's a felony for one
thing and for another like how can any
president do real diplomacy if he's
being undermined by permanent washington
like why shouldn't we be worried about
that you know i i think this is the key
point for me at least when i look at the
trump years a lot of people obviously
ask me why weren't you as worried as
other people on you know the left about
the trump presidency and my reason was
was because what i saw in opposition to
the trump presidency was something far
more dangerous than anything that i
thought he would be capable of doing
which is that they took their masks off
they made clear the cia the pentagon the
permanent military and security state
inside the united states that they were
willing to intervene in u.s politics to
undermine the elected president the very
first article i wrote before trump was
even inaugurated in january 17 2017 was
headlined the deep state goes to war
with the elected president the fact that
we have a deep state that the u.s media
was cheering they were thrilled that
these generals they were heralding as
heroes for ignoring trump's orders for
keeping classified information away from
him from manipulating him for subverting
his decisions they were cheering these
generals as saving us from our elected
leader which is the definition of a deep
state at the same time as they were
calling anyone who was pointing out that
we have a deep state unhinged crazy
conspiracy theorist that to me is the
most dangerous development of the last
five years is that unelected generals
intelligence operatives irrigated into
themselves while the media cheered the
power to override our democracy whenever
they thought that it was in our best
interest to do so and that leaves the
entire population powerless you know
your vote doesn't matter and that that
makes the society super volatile and
dangerous and i agree with you 100 i
used to laugh at the term the deep state
but it's totally real unfortunately
glenn greenwald i appreciate your coming
on today thank you
good to be with you talker thanks hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else